[موسيقى]
هذه الطماطم جاهزة للقطف
لكنها تنمو في وسط
الصحراء
حيث تكون الزراعة التقليدية مستحيلة
خارج أبو ظبي مباشرة.
الزراعة
لتزدهر والسبب في متابعة ذلك
هو أنني أردت أن أفعل شيئًا مؤثرًا ،
هذا الحل الوحيد يعالج الأمن الغذائي
، ويتعامل مع التنويع الاقتصادي والاستدامة للحفاظ على المياه
، كل
ذلك بمطرقة واحدة على
الرغم من مناخ الشرق الأوسط القاسي
حيث يمكن أن تصل درجات الحرارة في الصيف
إلى 120 درجة فهرنهايت  تعتبر الظروف
داخل هذا الدفيئة مثالية
لنظام متقدم يُعرف باسم الزراعة البيئية الخاضعة للرقابة ، حيث يقوم
تلقائيًا
بضبط درجة حرارة ضوء الشمس
والرطوبة بناءً على البيانات والقياسات ،
لذا فإن الطريقة التي تعمل بها هي وجود
أجهزة استشعار داخل البيت الزجاجي ، لذلك هناك
مجموعة متنوعة من أجهزة الاستشعار المختلفة ، لذلك على
سبيل المثال نقيس  درجة الحرارة
نقيس hu  midity نحن نقيس بعض
نقاط البيانات المهمة ، وهذا ما
تعلمته أنني أمتلك بشكل فعال إنترنت
الأشياء ، هناك عناصر معينة
في داخل منشأتنا حيث نقوم فقط
بتتبع كيفية أدائها
على الرغم من أن النظام آلي
لا يزال التدخل البشري ضروريًا
للجودة  التحكم ، لذا فأنا الوسيط
بين نقل ما تخبرني به الخطة
إلى أن التكنولوجيا قطاع مبتكر للغاية ، حيث يعمل
آلاف الأشخاص في
جميع أنحاء العالم ويقول الخبراء إن
التحول الكامل للزراعة كما
نعلم لم يأت بعد ، وهناك
فوائد من  تمتلك أنواعًا تقليدية
وحديثة
من المزارع لأنها توفر
أنواعًا مختلفة من المواد الغذائية من حيث
الجودة ولكن التغيير قادم بالفعل إلى
دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة التي
تستورد حاليًا أكثر من 80 في المائة من
إنتاجها وهو نموذج مكلف
ويصعب تحمله على حد سواء  الشرق الأوسط
لتحقيق الاكتفاء الذاتي الذي يمكن أن
يحمي المنطقة من
المشاكل المحتملة لتوريد الغذاء على
الصعيد الدولي
وبينما لا تزال التكنولوجيا في
مراحلها الأولى ، يمكن للابتكارات في الزراعة
أن تشهد فوائد على نطاق عالمي
من حيث التهديدات العالمية للأمن الغذائي
تظهر أن إنتاج
الغذاء سيتضاعف بحلول عام 2050
عليك تحديث التكنولوجيا في
الزراعة لدفع  الزراعة إلى
آفاق جديدة ويمكن أن يبدأ كل شيء مع
هذه الأنهار الطماطم مات سي إن إن